in this video i'm going to expose you to
what is maybe one of at least the top
five most useful formulas in mathematics
and if you've seen many of my videos you
know that i'm not a big fan of
memorizing things but i will recommend
you memorize it with the caveat that you
also remember how to prove it because i
don't want you just to remember things
and and not know where they came from
but with that said let me show you what
i'm talking about it's the quadratic
quadratic
formula
and as you might guess it is to solve
for the roots or the zeros of quadratic
equations so let's speak in very general
terms then i'll show you some examples
so let's say i have an equation of the
form
a x squared plus b x
plus c is equal to zero you should
recognize this this is a quadratic
equation where a b and c are well a is
the coefficient on the x squared term or
the second degree term b is the
coefficient on the x term and then c is
you could imagine the coefficient on the
x to the zero term where it's the
constant term now given that you have a
general quadratic equation like this the
quadratic formula tells us that the
solutions to this equation are
x is equal to
negative b
plus or minus the square root
of
b squared minus 4ac
all of that
over
2a i know it seems crazy and convoluted
and hard for you to memorize right now
but as you get a lot more practice
you'll see that it actually is a pretty
reasonable formula to stick in your
brain someplace
and you might say gee this is a wacky
formula where did it come from and in
the next video i'm going to show you
where it came from but i want you to get
from get used to using it first but it
really just came from completing the
square on this equation right there if
you complete the square here you're
actually going to get this solution and
that is the quadratic formula right
there so let's apply it to some problems
let's start off with something that we
could have factored just to verify that
it's giving us the same answer so let's
say we have
x squared plus 4 x
minus 21 is equal to 0. so in this
situation a is equal to let me do that
in a different color
in this situation
a is equal to 1 right the coefficient on
the x squared term is 1.
b is equal to 4 b is equal to 4 the
coefficient on the x term
and then c is equal to negative 21
the constant term and let's just plug it
in the formula
so what do we get we get x
this tells us that x is going to be
equal to
negative b
negative b is negative
4 negative 4 i put a negative sign in
front of that negative b
plus or minus
the square root of b squared b squared
is 16 right 4 squared is 16
minus 4
times a which is 1. times c
which is negative 21. so we could put a
21 out there and that negative sign will
cancel out
just like that with that actually let me
this is the first time we're doing it
let me not
skip too many steps so negative 21 just
so you can see how it fit in and then
all of that
all of that over 2 times a over 2 times
a a is 1 so all of that over 2.
so what does this simplify or hopefully
it simplifies so we get x
is equal to negative 4 plus or minus the
square root of see we have a negative
times a negative that's going to give us
a positive
and we have 16
plus let's see this is 6 4 times 1 is 4
times 21 is 84. 16 plus 84 is a hundred
that's nice
it's a nice perfect square all of that
over two and so this is going to be
equal to negative 4
plus or minus 10
over 2
we could just divide both of these terms
by 2 right now so this is equal to
negative 4 divided by 2 is negative 2
plus or minus 10 divided by 2 is 5. so
that tells us that x
x could be equal to negative 2
plus 5 which is 3
or
x could be equal to negative 2
minus 5 which is
negative 7. so the quadratic formula
seems to have given us an answer for
this you can verify just by substituting
back in that these do work or you could
even just try to factor this right here
you say what two numbers when you take
their product you get negative 21 and
when you take their sum you get positive
four well that's so you'd get x plus
seven times
x minus three is equal to negative 21
notice 7 times negative 3 is negative 21
7 minus 3 is positive 4 you would get x
plus
sorry it's not negative 21 is equal to
zero there should be a zero there so you
get x plus seven
is equal to zero or
x minus three is equal to zero x could
be equal to negative seven or
x could be equal to three so it
definitely gives us the same answer as
factoring so you might say hey why
bother with this crazy mess and the
reason we want to bother with this crazy
mess is it'll also work for problems
that are hard to factor and let's do a
couple of those let's do some hard to
factor problems right now
so let's
scroll down get some
fresh real estate let's rewrite the
formula again just so we have in case we
haven't had it memorized yet x is going
to be equal to negative b plus or minus
the square root of b squared minus 4 ac
all of that
over
2 a now let's apply this to another
problem
let's say
we have let's say we have
the equation
3
x squared
plus
6
x
is equal to negative 10. well the first
thing we want to do is get in the form
where all of our terms are on the left
hand side so let's add 10 to both sides
of this equation
we get 3
x squared plus 6x plus 10
is equal to
0
and now we can use the quadratic formula
so let's apply it here so a is equal to
3 that is a
this is
b
and this right there is c
so the quadratic formula tells us the
solutions to this equation the roots
of this
of this of this quadratic function i
guess we could call it x is going to be
equal to negative b negative b b is six
so negative 6
plus or minus the square root
of b squared b is 6. so we get 6 squared
minus 4
times a which is 3
times c which is 10.
stretch out the radical a little bit all
of that over
2
times a
2 times a 2 times
3. so we get x is equal to negative 6
plus or minus the square root of
36
36
minus this is interesting minus 4
times 3 times 10 so this is
minus
this is minus let me make sure yeah 4
times 3 times 10 so it was minus 120
minus
120
all of that over all of that over 6. so
this is interesting you might already
realize why it's interesting what is
this going to simplify to 36 minus 120
is what that's 84 if i'm doing my let me
120
minus 36
we make this into a 10 then this will
become an 11. this is a 4. it is 84. so
this is going to be equal to negative 6
plus or minus the square root of but not
positive 84 that's if it's 120 minus 36
we have 36 minus 120 it's going to be
negative 84.
negative 84
all of that
all of that over 6. so you might say gee
this is crazy what do the silly
quadratic formula you're introducing me
to sal it's worthless it just gave me a
square root of a negative number it's
not giving me an answer and the reason
why it's not giving you an answer at
least an answer that you might want
is because this will have no real
solutions
no
real
solutions in the future we're going to
introduce something called an imaginary
number which is a square root of a
negative number and then we can actually
express this in terms of those numbers
so this actually does have solutions but
they involve imaginary numbers so this
actually has no real solution we're
taking the square root of a negative
number so the b squared with the b
squared minus 4ac if this term right
here
is negative then you're not going to
have any real solutions and let's verify
that for ourselves let's get our
graphing calculator out and let's graph
this
let's graph this equation right here
so let's get the graph the y is equal to
that's what i had there before so you
have 3
x
let me clear this right so i get 3
x squared plus 6
x
plus 10.
so that's the equation we're going to
see where it intersects the x axis where
does it equal 0 so let me
graph it
let's graph it notice this thing just
comes down and then goes back up its
vertex is sitting here above the x-axis
and it's upward opening it never
intersects the x-axis so at no point
will this expression will this function
equal 0 at no point will y equal 0 on
this graph so once again the quadratic
formula seems to be working let's do one
more example you can never see
enough examples here and i want to do
ones that are you know maybe not maybe
not so obvious to factor so let's say
we get let's say negative 3 x squared
plus
x
plus one is equal to zero now let's try
to do it just having the quadratic
formula in our brain
so
the x the x's that satisfy this equation
are going to be negative b this is b so
negative b is negative 12 plus or minus
the square root of b squared of 144
that's b squared
minus 4
times a which is negative 3
times c which is 1
all of that
all of that over 2 times a over 2 times
negative 3. so all of that over negative
6
this is going to be equal to negative 12
plus or minus the square root of what is
this the negative times a negative they
cancel out so i have 144
plus 12. so that is
1
156
right 144 plus 12
all of that
all of that over
negative 6. now i suspect we can
simplify this 156 we can maybe bring
some things out of the radical sign so
let's attempt to do that
let's attempt to do that so let's do a
prime factorization of 156. sometimes
this is the hardest part simplifying the
radical
so 1
56 is the same thing as 2 times
78
78 is the same thing as 2 times
what that's 2 times is that 2 times 39
2 times
39 so square root of 156
so the square root of 156 is equal to
the square root
of 2 times 2 times 39 or we could say
that's the square root of 2 times 2
times the square root of 39 which and
this obviously is just going to be
square root of 4 or this is square root
of 2 times 2 is just 2.
2 square roots of
39 if i did that properly let's see 4
times 39 yeah it looks like it's right
120 yep
so this up here will simplify to
negative 12 plus or minus
2
times the square root of 39
all of that over negative 6.
now we can divide the numerator and the
denominator might be by 2 so this will
be equal to
negative
6 plus or minus the square root of 39
over negative 3 or we could separate
these two terms out we could say this is
equal to
negative 6 over negative 3
plus or minus
the square root
of 39 over negative 3. now this is just
a 2 right here right these cancel out 6
divided by 3 is 2. so we get 2
and now notice if this is plus and we
use this minus sign the plus will become
negative and the negative will become
positive but it still doesn't matter
right we could say minus or plus or
that's the same thing as plus or minus
the square root of 39
over 3. i think that's about as simple
as we can get this answer now i want to
make a very clear point of what i did at
that last step i did not forget
about this negative sign i just said it
doesn't matter it's going to turn the
positive into the negative it's going to
turn the negative into the positive let
me rewrite this so this right here can
be rewritten as 2
plus the square root of 39 over negative
3 or 2 minus the square root of 39 over
negative 3
right that's what the plus or minus
means it could be this or that or both
of them really now in this situation
this negative 3 will turn into 2 minus
the square root of 39 over 3 right i'm
just taking this negative out here the
negative and the negative will become a
positive and you get 2 plus the square
root of 39 over 3 right negative times a
negative is a positive so once again you
have 2
plus or minus the square root of 39 over
3. 2 plus or minus the square root of 39
over 3
our solutions
are solutions to this
to this equation right there let's
verify i'm just curious what the graph
looks like
so let's just look at it
so let's
look
let me clear this where's the clear
button
so we have
negative 3
x squared
plus 12
x
plus 1
and let's graph
it let's see where it intersects the x
axis goes up there and then back down
again
and then
so what are the
so 2 plus or minus the square see square
root of 39 square root of 39 is going to
be a little bit more than 6 right
because square 36 is 6 squared so it's
me a little bit more than 6. so this is
going to be a little bit more than 2. a
little bit more than 6 divided by 3 is a
little bit more than 2. so you're going
to get one value that's a little bit
more than 4 and then another value that
should be a little bit less than one
and that looks like the case you have
one two three four you have a value
that's pretty close to
four
and then you have another value
that is
a little bit a little bit maybe looks
close to zero but a little bit less than
that so anyway hopefully you found this
application of the quadratic formula
helpful